salut julien ça va justement je me
demandais tu as déjà remarqué que non
mais attends tu fais quoi là je tente un
truc entre eux pour leur nouvelle miss
corps mais on en parle avant peut-être
non mais oui évidemment à la tumeur on
m'a plus tu
[Musique]
ça fait maintenant plus d'un an que
détesté existe à l'euro à ça et je me
suis dit que c'était le bon moment pour
faire un petit bilan avec vous juste
avant l'été
oui parce que cet été comme l'année
dernière on va ralentir la cadence
une vidéo toutes les deux semaines au
lieu d'une vidéo par semaine parce que
de toute façon tout le monde a beaucoup
mieux à faire mais on va quand même de
traiter des sujets estivaux un des
sujets de vacances pour ceux qui ont la
chance d'en avoir mais aussi pour les
autres alors venant en ce petit bilan
cette année on a tenté des nouveaux
formats léger tester les dans son corps
avec des invités et même une espèce de
vlog sur mes séances de laser
on va continuer parce que j'aime bien et
qu'apparemment vous aussi pour la
rentrée chez d'autres idées et d'autres
projets mais je me suis dit que ce
serait pas mal que vous me disiez vous
ce que vous avez envie de voir sur dtc
alors évidemment je promets pas de
pouvoir tout faire mais s'il ya des
idées intéressantes qui sont réalisables
on s'entend s'il ya des demandes qui
reviennent beaucoup je vous promets de
me pencher très sérieusement sur la
question donc n'hésitez pas donnez moi
vos idées fait moi vos demandes dans les
commentaires de cette vidéo tant que
vous êtes là et tant que je suis là j'en
profite aussi pour vous dire que je
reçois énormément de messages de plus en
plus de messages auxquels j'essaye de
répondre à tous les coups mais il y en a
beaucoup
j'ai pas mal de trucs à faire donc
parfois je traîne
je suis désolé vraiment je fais le max
en tout cas vraiment un grand merci pour
votre confiance ça fait vraiment chaud
au coeur dans ses messages certains
d'entre vous me demandent des conseils
ou mon avis sur un problème de santé
très précis qui les touchent
personnellement j'essaie toujours de
répondre mais attention et y ai bien
conscience de deux choses d'abord je
suis pas médecin je suis infirmier et
ensuite un médecin pour pouvoir vous
aider il a besoin de vous voir de
discuter avec vous de vous examinez de
connaître vos dossiers etc et tout ça de
toute façon ça n'est pas possible en
échangeant des mails ou des messages sur
facebook
donc allez voir votre médecin vous êtes
aussi très nombreux à me demander si
vous pouvez venir parler dans dtc de
votre particularité avoue ce soit une
maladie physique ou mentale un handicap
etc
alors ça me touche beaucoup mais c'est
très complexe pour plein de raisons et
notamment parce que vous êtes très
nombreux
je vous promets je vais me pencher sur
la question et essayer de réfléchir à
une solution pour finir ce bilan et
parce que vous avez sûrement plein de
questions à me poser
vous propose une petite faq d un an
alors là encore direction les
commentaires posez moi toutes les
questions vous voulez sur des pc sur moi
sur ce que vous voulez et je reviens
très bientôt pour y répondre
donc on fait le bilan du bilan dans les
commentaires dites moi ce que vous
attendez de dtc pour la saison prochaine
et posez moi vos questions pour la faq
voilà détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo puis pour la faq
bien sûr d'ici là mettez vous bien et
surtout bien
non vraiment je te jure avant de tenter
des trucs je préférerais qu'on en parle
bien sûr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]